Live transferring the samples. There is a correct way to do this and I'm going to teach
it to you right now. The first thing I want to mention is this, if you are somebody that
has a job, if you are somebody that doesn't have the ability or doesn't want to have to
be glued to their phone all day every day, welcome to the club. I'm somebody where if
I get a call in the middle of the day and I picked up every single call, I would never
get anything done. My mind would be here and it would be here and it would be here. I have
to put my phone on silent. For some of you guys that are trying to get a hold of me sometimes,
that's why. I have to put my phone on silent for this to work, for me to be able to do anything,
to be productive at all. I totally understand that and I don't want you guys to worry.
If you are somebody that can't answer in the day because of a job or anything else,
it's okay. Here's what I do is I wait, I let all my calls go to voicemail or missed call or whatever
and then I put a slot of time in my calendar every day and I on my time go and look at my missed
calls and I call them back. These are the leads. I call them back and do the live transfers on my
time. If you're somebody that's like, oh, this isn't going to work for me because I have a job,
it's fine. You can do it after work. You can do it on your lunch break. You can do it on
Saturdays and if you're like, oh my gosh, I don't get off work until five, doesn't matter.
People actually answer the phone more after work. Don't stress it. It's not the end of the world.
I'm just going to teach you guys really quick the best way to do the live transfer.
First thing I want to mention is a lot of people get confused with this. They're like, well,
do you call the lead and then you hook the business owner with the lead live? Here's the
process that I do. Just a quick overview. If I haven't hooked a business owner, let's say I'm
in my first pre-sale, my first campaign, my first deal or a deal. I haven't hooked a business owner.
I've set up the campaign. I've done my niche research. I'm good to go. I've done my city
research. I'm good to go. I've built my list. I've set up my ad and a lead comes in. What I
will typically do is I will get ahold of the lead. Let's say the lead's name is Janet. I don't know
why I really like using the name Janet for this example, but I'm going to use Janet. Janet calls.
I call her back. By the way, if you do call back, I want you to say the following. Hey, Janet,
this is Nick with St. George Tree Service. You might not know it's Janet. The only reason you
would know it was Janet is if she filled out a form. Let's just say, hey, this is Nick with
St. George Tree Service. By the way, I'm actually calling you from my cell phone. It's been a crazy
day, so I apologize for the weird area code. I'm guessing you need an estimate. If you notice how
I did that, I brought up the objection first because I know she's already thinking, what the
heck is your weird area code? I have the weirdest area code ever. I bring that up first and I assume
I'm like, hey, I'm guessing you need an estimate. I don't say, hey, do you need an estimate? Yes,
no question usually leads to a no. Even if they need one, they'll just go, oh, wait, what? Hey,
I'm guessing you need an estimate. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I do. If you do call back, I want you to
say something to that extent of, hey, this is Nick with such and such company. You're going to act,
by the way, as the operator and you're going to let them know you're calling from your cell phone
because it's been a crazy day or you're on the road or you're out and about or whatever, or that's
just the number you grew up with because you want them to know that we are local. We want them to
know that the website is local. The first step is you're going to call the lead or answer the lead
and you are going to act as the operator, meaning you're going to act like you're just sitting there
answering the phone for the company. You work for the business owner or whatever. I typically,
if I'm answering it live, I'll say the same thing. Hey, this is Nick with St. George Tree Service.
I'm guessing you need an estimate. Okay, cool. Let me grab your information. Okay, cool. What's
your address? Awesome. What's the best number to reach yet? Awesome. Okay, cool. Zip code.
I'll get all the information and I'll say this. All right, Janet. What I'm going to do is the
business owner, I'm going to get a hold of him and we're going to get you scheduled. He is on
a job right now. He's typically out running about doing estimates. Let me get a hold of him and
we'll be reaching back out ASAP. If you don't hear from us for a minute, it's because he's on
a job. Like I said, and by the way, I might be calling from an 854 area code. That's just my
cell phone, so don't worry about it. That's just me. We will be in touch very shortly. Awesome,
Janet. Thank you. Now, Janet, the lead is teed up because keep in mind, I haven't called the
business owner. Now, this is going to change. Once we call the business owner, this live transfer
process becomes more simple because we can immediately just transfer it over. For this
first one, I just have Janet teed up. Okay, so Janet's teed up and now we go and hook the
business owner. Okay, so go back to the last step and you're going to hook the business owner. So,
you're going to use the script and you got Janet and that's the lead that you're going to use.
Okay, so now we got a hold of the business owner and if you remember from last module,
if you didn't watch it, go watch it. We tell the business owner, hey, save this number right here
or save XYZ number, whatever number is going to be doing the live transfer. We are going to be
calling you and there's going to be a live person on the phone that wants an estimate. Okay,
you're going to hook the business owner and then what I will do is I'll hang up with the business
owner and then I will call Janet back. Okay, so I'll call Janet. Hey, Janet, it's Nick again with
St. George Tree Service again. Sorry for the weird area code. I know, I know. Cool. Hey, I actually
have Jim. I just barely spoke with him. He is kind of out and about right now but he wants to just
get you scheduled. So, hang on one second. I'm going to patch you in with him so we can get you
on the calendar and come give you a free estimate. Okay, so give me one second. Boom. I put her on
or I just wait and I push add call. Now, some of you guys are like, I'm overseas and I don't have
an iPhone or this doesn't work. There's a ton of tools. Guys, search the group, ask the questions.
There are tools. Everyone has found a workaround for this. I do know CallRel has an option where
you can get a phone number so you don't have to use your own cell phone and you can do a merge
feature. There's a lot of ways around this. Do not disrupt your hands and say, oh, it doesn't work
for me because I'm not in the U.S. and I don't have an iPhone or whatever. There is always a
solution so don't be that guy, don't be that lady. That's the first thing. Anyway, just a quick
caveat. Janet's right there and I push add call and I then push add call and I go find Jim and I
call Jim. Now, the way this works with the live transfer is she's going to be on mute and I'm
going to be speaking with Jim. Jim answers, hey Jim. I'm going to use my other hand so we know
we're talking to Jim. Hey Jim, Nick here again. Hey, I actually, like I told you, I had that lead,
that job, her name is Janet on the phone right now. So I just, to make it simple, I just told
her I work for you. I'm going to put you guys on a three-way call really quick and I'm just going
to have you schedule her. Just so you know, she has an oak tree, she needs it removed,
she's gotten a couple estimates, blah, blah, blah, and she's at 84790 just so you know. But again,
I just acted like I work for you so give me one second. Okay, cool. Okay, Jim's good. Jim's good,
Janet's good. Then I push this button that says merge. So I merge the call. Boom. Now everybody's
on the call. So what I say now is I go, hey Janet, can you hear me? Awesome. Hey Jim, can you hear me?
Cool. Hey guys, so Jim, this is Janet. She's the one I was telling you about. She needs her tree
removed. She's over at this street address. And Janet, this is Jim. He's my boss. He's the owner.
He's the one that's going to be coming and taking a look and giving you a free estimate. Anyway,
awesome guys. I'm going to take myself off the call. Appreciate it. And thanks again. Put yourself
on mute, okay? And your work is done. And now what you're going to do is you are going to listen,
okay? You're going to listen and you're going to listen to the business owner. You're going to make
sure he doesn't screw it up. You're going to listen to the business owner. Make sure he doesn't try to
undercut you. You're going to listen to the business owner. Make sure he schedules an estimate.
Make sure he does it correctly and he's not passive in all this different stuff and he's
not dropping price. This is going to give you an opportunity to see if this is a business owner you
want to work with, okay? So you're going to put yourself on mute and you're going to listen,
okay? You're going to listen to these calls. And I never ever jump back in on the call unless
I have to. So if the business owner, or sorry, if the customer starts going,
yeah, and maybe she thinks I'm off the call or whatever, she goes, yeah, so I thought I called
St. George Tree Service or I thought I called Southern Utah Tree Service, like, who are you?
Then I'll jump back in and go, hey, sorry, Janet, I'm still here. I just wanted to explain this.
The name of the company is Jim's Tree Service. That's just one of our websites. So just to clear
up that confusion. Anyway, go ahead, guys. I'll jump back in if necessary, but it's very, very,
very rare. It's only to save the deal if I can just see it's going sideways. Or if the business
owner starts going, yeah, this guy just called me out of nowhere, then I'll cut him off and be like,
hey, bro, I'm still on the line. I'm going to control that process, that handoff, because,
guys, this is digital gold. I'm not just going to let them screw up a lead, but I'm also not
going to jump in and be all weird. But the biggest thing is you guys want to listen to how these
business owners are handling the customer. All right, guys, the last thing that I want to mention
is what happens if you call Janet and you tell the business owner, answer your freaking phone,
save my number, blah, blah, blah. Then you call Janet, you get ahold of Janet, you go to transfer
the call and freaking business owner still doesn't answer. And it is very frustrating. I totally
understand that because now you're like, oh my gosh, Janet's going to think I look like I'm an
idiot. Here's what you're going to do. You're not going to panic. You're not going to be weird.
You're simply going to tell Janet, you're going to say, hey, Janet, he must have got tied up on
another job or on a call. So here's what we'll do. This is going to be the easiest thing just to make
sure it's okay with you. I'm going to just put you, in fact, don't ask. Don't ask. I don't know
why you even said that. Don't freaking ask if it's okay with you. Just do. Hey, Janet, here's what
we're going to do. He's on another job, whatever. I'm actually going to put you in a three-way group
text with me, you, and him. And he's going to message you and find a time to call you and get
you scheduled for an estimate. Okay? So watch for that here in just a moment and we will be out very
soon. And then what you're going to do is you're going to do the same thing. You're going to have
them both on the group text. Hey, Janet, this is Jim. Jim, this is Janet, blah, blah, blah, just like
you would on a live transfer. But what this three-way text allows you to do is it allows you to
monitor the whole situation, allows you to watch and see if the business owner even gets a hold
of the lead, if he even is taking action, if he's even incentivized to go after it. Because
sometimes you'll send these leads and you think, oh, these guys are calling these leads. They're
not. Okay? So you doing the three-way text, it lets the business owner know, hey, I'm watching
this thing and you better be texting her back because I just gave you a job. Okay? So that is
the next best option if the business owner does not answer. Now, I don't want you thinking, oh,
I'll just do group text. I'll just do three-way text. I promise you, look me in the freaking eyes.
I promise you doing a live transfer is far better. But the second best option, if they don't answer
because it's going to happen, okay, you're going to do the three-way text. All right, guys. So that
is it for how to actually send and actually perform the live transfers. Do it exactly as I say.
You can use the same lines that I've used. You can use the verbiage that I've used. Act as the
operator. Do it exactly as I've done. I've tried. Trust me. And for the third time, I have tried
every way under the sun. This is the most effective, quickest way to get them leads and close
the deal.